self-isolation has played a critical
role in helping us to get this virus
under control by denying the virus the
human contact that it needs to spread
i'm so grateful to the many many people
right across the uk who have selflessly
done their duty
making sacrifices so they can help keep
the virus at bay
even though we've done everything in our
power to support the people who've had
to self-isolate
and yesterday we announced that we'll be
extending financial support until
september
i'm fully aware of how difficult it has
been
but we can take hope from the fact that
science
has shown us a solution just as it's
done
so many times in our fight against this
virus
and that solution is our vaccine
which we know offers huge protection
the latest data from public health
england shows that our vaccination
program
has saved over 27 000 lives
and has prevented over 7 million people
from getting covert 19
and it shows that both doses of covid19
vaccine
can reduce symptomatic infection by
almost
80 percent that protective wall
because that's what it is a protective
wall it means
that the odds have shifted in our favor
and we can look afresh
at many of the measures that we've had
to put in place
now this is especially important when
when almost two-thirds of adults that 64
have had both doses of a vaccine and so
have got the maximum protection
that the vaccine can offer as a result
we will soon be able to take a
risk-based approach
that recognizes the huge benefits that
the vaccines provide
both the people who get the job and to
their loved ones too
so mr speaker from the 16th of august
when even more people will have the
protection of both doses
and when modeling suggests the risks
from the virus will be even lower
anyone who's a close contact of a
positive case
will no longer have to self-isolate if
they have been fully vaccinated
if someone gets their dose their second
dose just before
or just after the 16th of august they'll
need to wait two weeks
after which their second jab can take
effect and give
them these new freedoms so this will
allow the vaccine
time to build up the maximum possible
protection those two weeks
now as we make this change we'll be
drawing on the huge capacity we've built
for testing and sequencing
and advising close contacts who are
fully vaccinated
to take a pcr test as soon as possible
so they can get certainty about their
condition
and of course anyone that tests positive
will have to self-isolate whether they
have had the jab
or not this new approach means
that we can manage the virus in a way
that's proportionate to the pandemic
while maintaining the freedoms that are
so important to us all
as honourable members will be aware
we're not currently offering vaccines
to most people under the age of 18.
so we thought carefully about how we can
make sure that young people
get the life experiences that are so
important to their development
while at the same time we're keeping
them safe from this deadly virus
so in line with the approach for adults
anyone under the age of 18 who is a
close contact of a positive case
will no longer have to self-isolate
instead they'll be given advice about
whether they should get tested dependent
on their age
and will need to self-isolate only if
they test
positive these measures will also
come into force on the 16th of august
ahead of the autumn school term